Hey,
what's going on?
How are you doing?
Um,
it's bill burns Monday morning podcast.
I literally,
literally have just woken up and decided that I have to do this fucking thing
cause I gotta go,
I gotta jump back on the bus,
jump back on the bus.
He had an overdue,
a Jackson,
Mississippi.
You know,
I'm nervous about Mississippi,
you know what I mean?
This is the one state that scares other southern states.
You know,
they just,
it's like the Texas of the south.
It's like,
um,
it's like the Ted Kennedy of the Kennedys.
What's another good example?
You know,
it's like the,
uh,
it's like the Kiwi or the birds.
It's just this little fucking state without winks,
you know?
Everybody's just hoping,
just hope of one day it's going to sprout.
It's fucking wings and something's going to happen.
I can be honest with you,
I don't know shit about Mississippi,
you know what I mean?
Although last night in Huntsville,
Alabama,
Bama,
Huntsville,
Alabama,
you know,
everybody around here calls it comes Phil.
You know,
they do.
Of course they do because what do you do?
Yeah.
Don't be adult like the town next to our towns better than your town.
We have the exact same fucking trees and there's an invisible line,
but our trees are better.
Right?
Nobody likes nobody.
Everybody makes fun of the town next to him.
Everybody makes fun of the state next to him.
Everybody makes fun of the country next to him.
It just keeps going and going and going and it ca are continence better in your
continent.
I like our ocean better than y'all Roshan writing.
Next thing you know,
he's shooting a couple of missiles.
Um,
so I'm on stage here in Huntsville.
You know what kills me was we were here for a day and a half and we got in the
night before and uh,
the same place that I performed at Dj Fontana was there the night before.
I swear to God and all,
a lot of the youngsters are going like,
oh my God,
who's Dj Fontana?
Or,
or,
or
no,
not that kind of Dj.
He backed up.
He was Elvis's drummer.
The real of this,
not the impersonator
Sukkot case.
You didn't know Elvis was,
I guess now he does like an Elvis tribute thing.
And I know a lot of you guys probably thinking,
that's fucking sad.
Well,
what's he supposed to do?
What are you supposed to do when you're a drummer and the guy that you back up
fucking dies at 42?
What are you going to do?
I mean,
you're going to live for another 30 fucking years.
You need some money,
right?
Well,
you goofball consult the lamb assault little blue.
You're going to do it.
Just find some guy that could do impersonation of him.
It's a tough gig being a drummer.
There's very few of them there.
When the fucking lead singer either tells him to fuck off,
you know,
or they die.
Usually the drummer's fucked.
The lead guitarist can somehow come up with the band.
Okay.
Now I'm trying to think.
Uh,
you know,
I would say Dave Grohl,
Dave Grohl was the only guy I've ever seen come out of that thing,
you know?
Okay.
And go on and be on top and actually be as big as his other band was.
None of those larger Nevana fence.
No one will ever eclipse nirvana.
Nirvana,
put hair metal down where belonged religious.
They just made these songs and like start off loud and they were quiet or loud
or quiet and then they will allow,
will allow to then that was it.
That was the Song Bay on ramped.
Could you do,
do,
um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about a babbling here as always.
So many ways.
Dj Fontana was there.
I could gone and I could,
I could,
could've met the guy.
I don't know if I could have met the guy,
but a fucking kills me.
I could at least see him play
a little bit.
Nice.
So anyways,
I want stage last night in Huntsville,
Alabama,
Huntsville,
Alabama.
And um,
I,
I mentioned that I didn't believe in God and it got really kind of quiet and
whatever,
and I was just like,
come on guy and I'm going drink it.
I'm just,
I just think I'm fertilizer when I'm dead.
I just go into the ground and that's my job.
I didn't think there's a beautiful thing.
I go into the ground and I make the soil richer.
Right?
Or maybe I become a fossil fuel for the next fucking thing that takes over the
planet and it doesn't like the town next to him.
It doesn't like to state and then so on and so forth.
Right.
Okay.
So me in the crowd yells Ah,
better not say that and miss shipping.
Oh God.
That was the creepiest thing.
I think anybody's ever said better not say that Mississippi.
I was right then somebody had j Geils fucking cute up.
My blood runs cold.
Um,
I dunno.
I'm looking forward to going.
I believe it or not.
I'm looking forward to going to Mississippi.
I'm looking forward to interacting with those people and I'm looking forward to
like a,
you know,
making a couple stereotypes go away.
Although I know there's going to be a lot that will reinforce it.
You know,
I know there's going to be a lot of,
stay on the main highways,
get off at like a burger king and then get the fuck back on the bus and get
outta here.
I know that might be elements of that,
but you know,
I did look up some comedy clubs and I started to see who was playing there.
And uh,
this is tour that's going around called the standing ovation toward that stars
some more,
some more.
Uh,
Tony Rock did a couple of dates aren't as Jay,
one of the funniest comics ever.
And um,
okay.
You know,
they all came through here.
I think they did already.
I Dunno does that second right?
They came down here.
They had a good time.
Cory Hoechlin came down here.
Um,
okay.
It's weird.
You would think that that would just be white comics coming down here with
Mississippi's fucking reputation.
Do you know?
All I found was as far as comics that I knew they were all black.
So anyways,
we'll see what happens
to all freckles.
I think I'll be fine.
I just don't need somebody with a fucking hardcore southern accent.
Go on a
tuck in if I don't say that Mississippi.
I uh,
I had another guy last night.
I'm getting deep in the south right now is what's going on.
Because last time I talked to you guys,
I think I was just rolling into Memphis and um,
okay.
You know,
since then we did tree for it,
then we did New Orleans and uh,
it was all good.
The Huntsville is the first time.
It was just like,
wow,
I'm really in the south here just with a couple of heckles because I was talking
about how,
you know,
Oh,
I love sec football and how I wanted to,
uh,
come through it,
go to Alabama game and a Auburn game.
And I would have loved to go to the Alabama Auburn game,
but it's,
you know,
it's Thanksgiving weekend every year and there's no fucking way,
you can ever make that game unless you live in Alabama.
You can't leave your wife,
you know,
if your wife had family,
you just can't do it.
Just fucking carved up to Turkey,
you know,
give sacks and then jump on a fucking red eye to Alabama,
which is what I would have to do.
Um,
although it is a Saturday game,
I might be able to get away with that.
Yeah,
I might be able to get away with it.
But anyways,
so I was just talking about,
uh,
I was saying how I liked both teams.
I was very being very impartial.
I was reside war Eagle Rove,
Todd's screaming.
It was fucking awesome.
And somehow I started talking about how fucking bad ass it is.
I said,
c'mon,
yeah
damn fans.
You got to admit that fucking eagle flying down from the top of the stadium
right on to the guy's arm.
He got to admit that's the shit he got admit.
That's the shit some Alabama Fam said,
my favorite thing was when the eagle flew into the glass.
I guess it went into like the luxury boxes.
It just flew right into it and they will laughing,
you know?
And I'm like,
yeah,
mostly like,
oh,
give me a fucking break.
It happened one God damn time.
I go,
sir,
how many fucking play glass windows if you walk in?
I walked into when your life and the guy was like,
no,
I have a walked in and here I go,
give me a fucking break.
I go,
when often when Auburn returned that field goal against Alabama,
you probably walked through the side of your house and the place went fucking
nuts.
Auburn flipped out screaming at Bama fans like right.
And then when it all died down,
somebody in the back yelled out,
go back to Mississippi
was just like,
and the crowd went right.
It was really very high school.
And I was like,
wait a minute,
I haven't been to Mississippi yet.
You know?
And not only that,
I've been fucking on your side Sir,
I brought him down.
But,
but on your side,
the whole fucking show here I am talking about,
you know,
equal pay and how if you just make women make the same amount of money,
these guys and you don't change anything else,
it's not fair.
Okay.
It's just something I'm doing on my act somewhat.
Yeah.
Believe it or not,
that bit is actually empowering to women
after I brow beat him.
You know,
it's a fun job.
Anyways.
So this is the Monday morning podcast.
I'd even say the date yet for April 27th the last Monday,
the last fucking Monday in April in 2015 they'll never be another Monday in
April,
2015 you can say that you were there,
you were there,
you lived it,
you enjoy.
Did you put your hands in that soil and you felt it?
Um,
so what are you going to do?
Huh?
How did you do this month?
How'd you do this month?
We had good husband,
a good father,
a good mother.
How?
Even chowing down.
Okay.
Mid doin.
All right.
What do you need to do?
You need to fat.
Shame yourself.
Check in on yourself.
Just checking in on you on the last Monday.
Yeah.
I actually had somebody come up to me and said,
Geez,
bell thought she going to be a lot bigger.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I'm average height.
He's like,
no fat or the way you should on yourself.
I said,
dude,
I've been killing it at the gym.
My friend.
I go to the gym everyday.
It's just become a part of your life.
And if you don't pay a fee where you go to the gym everyday,
you can't.
I said,
you'll go to that cookie gym everyday.
I keep saying every month you go to gym every day.
Um,
so that made me feel all right.
And by the way,
to all this fat shaming I've been doing,
making people fat,
shame themselves.
Uh,
I had a couple come up to me and said that collectively they had lost like 80
pounds.
I had a,
and then I've had like three or four different people say one guy had lost over
a hundred pounds.
The other guy lost 80,
and I think there was a 60 in there.
So there you go.
Okay.
You Watch that fucking show the biggest loser where they screaming in your face,
save money,
screaming your own face.
Go into the fucking bathroom,
take off your goddamn shirt.
See where you sit.
All right.
See where you're at in the rankings.
Be honest about your torso is looking at,
and I just look yourself in the mirror,
huh?
Brow beat itself.
And then you end on a positive note right after you fucking what the fuck is
going on,
right?
Then you bring it around in the end,
we're better than this,
right?
We get one life,
we get one body,
we're not fucking doing this,
and you have your turn it around and all you gotta do is you just get a break.
That fucking sugar salt thing.
When you wake up in the morning,
that thing that's telling you to get an egg mcmuffin and things it telling you
need fucking pancakes and all that shit.
You got no,
you know what?
Shut the fuck up.
You override it.
You override those cravings and you go down and you just make yourself some
fucking oatmeal,
nothing in it.
You fucking slam that down with the banana.
Some berries assumption like that and then you fucking,
you level yourself off.
What's that shit they give you when you're trying to get off heroin?
Methadone,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
OATMEAL is the food version of that.
Okay.
It's the food version of that.
By the way,
dude,
I,
I don't follow a couple of people on a Facebook and uh,
they just sent it,
all of these fucking links to what the fuck they're doing to our food supply
minutes.
Really?
God Damn scared.
It's really fucking scary,
you know?
I think that's how they're going to solve the population problem.
Next day I'm going to fucking turn the food in a poison.
There you go.
If nobody's allowed to say what is in the food,
it's terrifying.
Fucking apples that don't turn brown.
What is wrong with people?
What the fuck is wrong with those God damn people that work in those,
those corporations.
I,
you know that type of debt type list psycho shit.
You know,
you haven't played like your pick up boop,
a pickup hockey.
If you just feel you ever just play with a sociopath,
he,
you know,
you can play in for anything.
He just feel it.
That fucking person as willing to do anything.
It's unreal.
Speaking of which,
how about those Boston Celtics?
What a,
what a great God damn sees.
I've got to say that first before we get into the negativity of the game
yesterday.
And God knows I don't fucking watch the Celtics.
You know,
God knows I don't fucking why I still love him.
But you know,
you only got time for so much,
right?
You read the real fucking hoop guy.
Oh,
you're a hockey guy.
I don't know Joe,
Joe Barton.
It's the only guy I know that can talk intelligently and in depth about both.
I don't know how to fuck he does it.
Um,
but anyways,
the Celtics were in the playoffs.
We made the seventh seed basically don't have any stars.
It was a hell of a coaching job by that guy that everybody's saying is a great
coaching higher.
It's gonna repeat what other people say,
but actually watched the game.
I've actually watched Ben Ben Watching Hoop because I'm on tour here with lie
hadn't VRC and um,
okay.
You know,
it's just been,
uh,
you know,
I've been watching some of the stuff,
they've been like good games I guess.
But,
uh,
I watched the,
a lot of that Celtics game yesterday.
Hope it's Celtic pride.
We at least wouldn't get swept,
but,
um,
I got to tell you that fucking Kevin Love inches,
his shoulder,
you know,
and then he turns around and he blames sweet,
innocent,
beautiful flowing hippie hair co Kelly,
was it Kelly?
All Olynyk Avi say his name.
How dare he suggest that that was a dirty play.
You think that this is that I'm not being impartial here because of a Celtics
fan.
Okay.
The ball goes up.
It's to rim.
Okay.
Now,
right out of the gate,
it's already the Cavaliers fault because if dad fucking jerk off foot took the
shot,
hit the shot,
there was no way that Kelly would have been concerned about the left arm of,
of Kevin Love
and felt the need to create a link within his body and then turn to the side and
spoon with it.
Had the Cavaliers,
whoever the fuck it was.
I mean,
you get Lebron.
Why didn't you say I'm going to dunk on everybody?
Not,
we've got to take a shot.
Had to get fancy.
Right.
Rubbing it in.
I'm just fucking with you.
Um,
I don't even,
yeah,
I don't know anything about hoop.
Part of me wants to think that Kelly stinks cause he just looks like he stinks.
I don't know shit about who,
but I look at that guy and I look at it like that.
That's not the guy I'm picking.
Um,
we just look like one of the,
you don't like those spazzes you play with who just suck.
So they just,
they're always fucking grabbing you.
You don't remind him.
Remind me what I was a kid.
Okay.
And then me and my brother fell out of a tree simultaneously because when you're
trying to teach my other brother,
try and show me other brother,
it was as part of those,
this tree we used to climb up and um,
and you know,
the main trunk went up and then it's split.
Okay.
And as it went further up,
obviously the,
the gap got greater and greater.
Right.
Just like a horse legs.
Um,
there was the hort tree.
why couldn't the tree be giving birth?
Shut up,
Lee.
Uh,
so we got up to a certain height and there was no branches on one side,
one side of the trunk that went up until you got to a certain height.
And the only way to get over to the other side of the tree was you had to swing
across on this dead branch.
So my older brothers swung cross and then I swung across and then my younger
brother wouldn't fucking do it because it was a dead branch because you know,
he's like,
it's a dead branch.
I'm not doing it.
We're like,
yeah,
we way more than you.
And we did it and he wouldn't do it.
So we go,
all right,
what if we both hang on this fucking together?
Then if it doesn't break,
then you'll do it.
And he's like,
yeah.
So we both go out and we hang on the branch.
My brothers on the inside,
he weighs more.
I'm on the outside,
we hang on it,
it doesn't break.
We go,
all right,
come on man.
Let's go swing across the branch.
And he still wouldn't do it.
He goes,
do it one more time.
So this time I'm thinking like,
wow,
it's the fucking dead branch.
I want to get on the inside.
So I got on the inside,
my older brother got on the outside that go and say,
look,
it's safe.
It's fucking safe,
crack.
And the thing just snapped.
So we weren't going down to the ground and I'm coordinated.
My older brother is not coordinated and I'm fucking getting ready to land
somewhat.
In a way we'll,
I'll get hurt the least.
And as my brothers going down,
you know,
ass and back of the head first,
he reaches out and grabs my shoulder and pulls me into his uncoordinated
nightmare.
We slammed down on the ground,
he got knocked out.
I didn't,
I remember he got knocked out.
He was laying face down on the fucking dirt and he was going like,
Eh,
and we will meet my other brothers.
Would you laugh and think?
And he was fucking around.
And my dad had just happened to pull up.
He's like,
Christ,
you know,
I'm not gonna name names.
So he goes,
what's he,
what's he doing laying in the dirt?
He's like,
Oh,
for Christ sake.
He said unconscious.
Right.
But I remember like,
he fucking reached out and grabbed,
I said,
what the fuck are you grabbing on me for?
Cause he wasn't coordinated.
And that's how I feel,
uh,
that Kelly part of me thinks that he stinks so bad that that was actually him
playing basketball.
But my final verdict was it was dirty because I just never see anybody ever grab
somebody's arm like that in basketball.
And it was just weird.
Like,
what are you doing?
It was like he was carrying a giant Salami or some shit.
And then at the last second,
he liked fucking turned his body.
And I,
you know,
I'm going to have to side with cavalier fans.
I think that was a dirty fucking play.
And um,
you know,
I don't know.
It was good to see Parkinson's.
I don't know why we have a fucking traitor,
that guy,
you know,
I,
I don't know.
Maybe now,
I don't know about hope.
Maybe it was a good fucking move when,
when we traded him,
I didn't think that that was a good move,
but whatever.
Congratulations to the fucking cavalier and uh,
congratulates the Celtics for a great,
uh,
a great season.
But,
um,
I really hope that wasn't a dirty play because that's the number one thing that
I fucking hate.
I hate when he can't beat a team.
Then you just hurt their player.
And that just really affects the Cavaliers on the next level and just fans in
general.
If you could've seen a totally healthy fucking cavalier take on a,
I want to play the bucks of the bowl so it can be talking hope here.
MMM.
Okay.
Now one of the best guys is out and you might have fucked the whole season.
You weren't going to win anyways.
Why would you do that?
I Dunno.
I think it was a,
I think it was a dirty play.
Okay.
In fact,
it was so dirty.
I'm sure the Pittsburgh Penguins are calling Kelly Olynyk right now and asking
me if she could skate
till you die.
I'll tell you right now,
Kelly,
that is ring of honor level stuff here at the Pittsburgh Penguin Organization.
There's nothing we like better than someone who's willing to hurt somebody who's
better than them on another team during a deciding game in the playoffs.
Um,
that should be under the Pittsburgh Penguin logo.
Good Lord.
Have they had some of the worst,
most fucking reprehensible human beings on their team forever?
Um,
or they've had some great ones.
Okay.
I guess the smart,
it's like they fucking draft the Mario Lemieux and then they go,
all right,
who's going to try to end his career?
Let's get that guy to,
let's just make sure this fucking piece of shit is blowing out knees on the
other team and not blowing out our knees.
Maybe.
Maybe it's a fucking,
maybe.
Maybe it's an intelligent move.
I don't know.
I don't pretend to know things.
Sure.
You don't build.
Your whole fucking podcast is based on it.
I'll go fuck yourself.
MMM.
Anyway,
so let's do a little reading out loud.
Shall We?
You guys ready for this?
If had your morning coffee,
you fucking drug addicts.
I can't get my day going.
Is it like looking cuff?
You know,
that's why I never drank coffee.
Other than that,
the fact that it tastes like dirty water.
Um,
granted I never had it hot.
I used to drink my dad's when he went to work,
I take sips of it,
one of his fucking stone calls and uh,
you know,
that whole I'm going to be an adult and I just sip it was fucking disgusting.
I'm glad I never got into it.
People can't start the day.
They just sit there with their brown coffee,
stained fucking tastes.
Okay.
You know how many hours of your life,
how many days,
how many weeks a month,
a year life are you going to waste standing in a line at Starbucks?
Every time I go to a fucking airport,
the second they bring that thing up,
these junkies are just standing there.
You know,
like they're waiting for Springsteen tickets so they can do teach.
I love tea with the fucking fucking score to have,
uh,
some whip cream
coming out there,
you know,
with like a heroin shake.
Uh Oh gee,
Bill,
you just better than us in that area.
I am.
Alright.
Sherry's berries.
Everybody look who's back this fucking year.
Give mom the last bite.
Growing up.
Your mom always let you have the last bite.
Now it's her turn with a gift from Sherry's berries.
A good gift makes your eyes water the best gifts makes her mouth water to gross
treat.
Your mom does something sweet as Mother's Day offer.
For my listeners only in every other person that they advertise with a Sherry's
berries is offering giant,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at 1999 over a 40% savings.
Go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and type in my code.
Burr B U R R berries dipped in white milk and dark chocolaty goodness.
Top with chocolate chip nuts and decorative swizzle.
It's very interracial this year.
Huh?
Choose from Barry's cake.
Truffles,
Brownie pops.
You just have tub shit.
If you,
if you have a piece of cake on a,
on a tootsie roll,
whatever you call it,
a bomb pop.
What are the kids call him now?
A lollipop cake on a stick.
Pretzels in more just you just use my coat burpee.
You are when you ordered giant freshly juicy,
juicy,
delicious.
No,
I thought that was going to be something else at the end.
That's just giant,
fresh,
juicy,
delicious.
Here's the only way to get this amazing deal.
Freshly dip strawberries starting at 1999 this offers from my listeners only and
every other podcast that the advertise on when you use my code burpee,
you are our visit berries.com B r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone on the top right hand corner and type in.
Go to berries.com click on the microphone and enter the code [inaudible].
By the way,
everybody know that's ordered those so they're fucking delicious as much as I
make fun of him.
All right,
pro flowers.
Another old friend of the podcast is coming back.
Hey everybody.
Remember when we used to make macaroni art from mom or re gift random items
found around the house for Mother's Day?
Now you're older.
You can really appreciate that mom.
What mom has done over the years,
all right,
show her your appreciation show.
You show her you appreciate what she does with flowers from pro flowers.
Flowers is offering radio listeners 100 blooms with a free glass vase for just
1999 or make her day extra special and upgrade to a premium vase.
Please do that.
Everybody don't get to the shitty vase.
Get her vase that she can someday.
Take out your father with.
When she finds out that,
uh,
he lifts his Skidmark underwear on the stairway again and add chocolates for
nine 99 more.
Go to proflowers.com today and use my code Barbie.
You are our pro flowers are guaranteed to be fresh and beautiful for at least
seven days.
You choose the delivery date you want and it's guaranteed.
Here is the only way to get a hundred blooms with the free glass vase for just
1999 visit profe proflowers.com click the blue,
the blue microphone in the top right corner and type in bar.
That's proflowers.com click on the microphone and type in birth order today.
This offer expires Friday at midnight.
All right,
there you go.
Everybody.
Sherry's berries and some flowers you're off and running.
They don't have to do is comb your hair and show up like a decent human being.
Give her a hug and tell her yo lover.
All right,
the last one here in this chunk,
draft kings,
everybody they'll wait is finally out of a baseball season is here at last.
Everybody and the excitement continues all season long at draft kings that cap
the official daily fantasy partner of major league baseball.
Daily fantasy means no season long commitments,
just instant cash,
instant gratification.
Why wait until the end of the season to claim victory when you can win huge cash
everyDay@draftkings.com it's like a brand new season.
Every time you play just select two pitches and a position.
Players stay under the salary cap and you could be on your way to an enormous
payday.
Last year,
Peter from Colorado won a million bucks@draftkings.com in one day just playing
fen fantasy baseball.
Corey is giving hand jobs at a truck stop.
It all depends on how you gamble.
Hundreds of thousands of fantasy sports fans,
just like you have already cashed in@draftkings.com.
Now it's your turn.
Call to action.
Hurried it.
Draft kings.com now and enter the Promo code defense to play for free.
You could win part of the three hundred thousand three hundred million dollars
in prizes,
right?
They're being awarded this season.
Use Promo code defense for free entry now@draftkings.com draftkings.com that's
draft kings,
Dat camp.
Um,
speaking of truck stops,
we actually stopped at one somewhere in fucking Alabama or Mississippi when we
were coming up from,
uh,
New Orleans.
Do you know what it means to Miss New Orleans?
That's where my baby go goes.
She gives me a hand job.
She used humidity for a lubricant when she jerked my Dick in the middle of
Jello.
Pulling it out of my CEUs is stuck a suit.
Um,
but your day on decker way and keeping moving.
Sorry.
Uh,
yeah,
we stopped off at a truck stop and uh,
you know,
I had to relieve myself not once,
but twice,
if you know what I mean.
And I go into this fucking bathroom and there's some trucker already unit in
there dropping a deuce and I'm already laughing my ass off cause I'm like,
I'm only one toilet away and I'm on a bus,
what am I going to do?
I got to go and I'm like,
am I really going to take a dump next to a fucking trucker in Mississippi at a
truck stop?
I got to do it.
And then all of a sudden like every truck trucker from here to Tuscaloosa
fucking came in there and I had to leave.
It's like I can't fucking do it.
And I kept trying to walk in there,
you know,
when there was nobody there,
there was always five truckers and that original truck or never moved.
He was just sitting there just,
I dunno shitting his brains out or couldn't,
oh my God,
he had these awful white Seinfeld sneakers that were all fucking creased up and
dirty dad jeans.
It was one of the fucking low points of my standup career,
although I was laughing my ass off.
Cause VRC goes in there and he comes back out and I just started laughing.
He,
he says going to do it.
I can't,
I need,
I can't.
Um,
it's fucking,
it's not all luxury being on a tour bus,
just put it that way.
But um,
oh I didn't mention,
you know,
a lot of people gave me shit cause when I would go to these cool places,
I never mentioned what they are cause I don't want to ruin them for the locals
but fuck it.
I'll switch that up.
You know,
cause people are going to do,
you don't realize how arrogant you are that you feel like,
you know,
you just mentioning it on your podcast is going to ruin those places.
All right,
so let's see.
So we went to New Orleans,
New Orleans and um,
I played this amazing theater that I could not pronounce a beginning was an s
and a only know is Bob Dylan was going to be performing in the next week,
which is a pretty big fucking thrilled be performing on a stage that he performs
on that because that's what he's selling these days.
He just loves this place so much.
Um,
and it was just an amazing fucking show and it's such a great time.
And then we had a couple of days off,
so the next night,
you know,
he,
this is the deal with New Orleans.
If you go to New Orleans and he just go to Bourbon Street,
if you're in your 20s,
you probably enjoy,
if you're in your thirties or older,
you're going to be like,
not only is this fucking an absolute shit show,
this is one of the worst cities in the country.
It's dirty,
it's evil,
it's dirty and evil,
whatever.
Sorry,
I needed a third one.
However,
if you get the fuck out of there and you go in,
you go north of the Goddamn city,
whatever fucking direction it is,
um,
you're going to see those beautiful houses and you will literally go from going
like this fucking places.
Awful too.
Wow.
I could live here.
So we went to a place called a commander's palace for some of the best seafood
I've ever fucking had.
A,
if you go into New Orleans,
I'm telling you right now,
take your wife over there.
Okay.
Watch your,
shut the fuck up.
No,
sorry.
That just for some reason was thinking Harvey cartel,
when he tests,
he has to take the gun and smash it on the nose.
Once you shut the fuck up,
let's go get a Taco.
Um,
and then afterwards we wanted to go smoke a cigar and,
um,
you know,
it's like I knew some cigar bars down around the French quarter and I was like,
I don't want to go down there.
You know,
you go down there and it's just a bunch of drunks.
It's just,
it's like the Jerry Springer show,
you know,
the Jerry Springer show just has the worst representation of every race,
every demographic.
When you go down to Bourbon Street,
that's what you have.
You have the worst from every state.
And then you have the worst people in New Orleans hovering around them,
trying to take advantage of them in any way possible self.
I was like,
there's gotta be something better.
So I waited,
was the shit.
Um,
and he told us about this place called a dose Jeff Ace dose,
like a Spanish for two,
d,
O s e and then Jeff A's,
j e f,
f,
e as they had these great cigars and then they had this live music that we
listened to.
Oh,
did I already tell you this?
I think I mentioned it on the podcast last week.
I'm sorry dude,
I don't even know where the fuck around right now.
Um,
but we just had the best,
I'll even say it again.
We had the best time,
best food,
best place I've been to as far as where to eat in New Orleans and uh,
just the coolest fucking bar.
This unbelievable live music.
And I'm telling you,
if you,
if you do that alone,
you'll fucking,
you want to go to New Orleans every goddamn year.
Um,
so anyways,
having said all of that,
let's congratulate everybody who got out of the first round in the NHL playoffs.
All right.
I Dunno what's going on with Detroit and Tampa Bay.
I haven't been able to keep up with that.
Congratulations to the Minnesota wild,
you know,
great series for you guys and my condolences to St Louis Blues fans.
I mean I'd,
I know what the fuck he got to do.
What are the St Louis Blues got to fucking do to get out of the first round of
the fucking playoffs?
That was the team.
I was like,
oh this is the guys I'm gonna root for these fucking guys.
I thought they were going to make a run at least go a couple of series.
Fucking brutal.
What did St Louis fucking blues fans due to the hockey gods?
They really are like the fucking Los Angeles Clippers of,
of hockey.
It's just,
they're just never going to get out of the first round.
I don't know shit about who,
but I'll tell you right now when the fucking,
the Spurs won game two,
that series was over.
It's over.
They're going to turn on every fucking thing that they know about how to win a
championship and it's going to be done because the clippers,
they don't have it.
And I can say that cause I don't want troop.
So congratulations to them.
Congratulations to the ranges.
I know the ducks won Calgary flames.
Um,
who else is out there that I'm forgetting?
There's gotta be one other series.
Oh,
the Blackhawks.
Blackhawks won.
So who do you like out there?
Black Hawks.
Flames,
ducks,
Minnesota.
I mean,
he got to go with the experience,
right?
You gotta go with the Blackhawks even though they fucking every fucking other
period they got a different guy in there.
Crawford than the other guy.
Then Crawford and the other guy and then the other guy and then Crawford think
are off and then the other guy.
But somehow they made it work.
Somehow they made it work.
So,
um,
who am I rooting for out the I'll,
I'll root for the Calgary flames and want to root for them because in 1989,
they beat the Montreal Canadiens back when the Bruins could never beat them.
Um,
so that was nice to watch it.
So I've always liked Calgary because of that.
And then Laney,
Mcdonald's,
they got the fucking red headed guy with the psycho mustache.
C'Mon dude.
It was fucking killing it.
The guy looked like he just stepped out of a fucking mind shaft and then he'd go
in and score God damn goal.
Right.
Then he'd smile like it was Christmas.
How could you not love that guy?
Right.
Um,
it's been a lot of great fucking Calgary flames over the fucking years.
Our McGuinness dirt,
he's got the hat is fucking shot and hockey.
It's like fucking 200 miles an hour.
Right.
All right,
sorry.
And let's see over in these two else.
Who else wants it?
Just feel like I'm forgetting to can grow all.
Let's see.
The,
the,
the fucking,
we got a game seven dawn,
we between the islanders and the capitals ranges.
One,
I don't know what happened with Detroit.
Okay.
And uh,
Tampa Bay.
But uh,
like I said,
congratulations to everybody and that wraps up my hockey talk.
I'm fucking with you.
You silly sock.
Frenchies you fucking assholes.
You fucking assholes.
Almost got pushed to a game seven after going up three zero.
And I didn't write why didn't talk one line is shit cause I didn't want to jinx
it all was I hope.
And that you guys went down that way,
but then part of me wasn't cause the Bruins did that and then the next year we
want a cup and I don't ever want you guys to win another one,
but I have to begrudgingly grudgingly admit you got your best shot and years
this year.
You do.
Although I've got to tell you,
you're very easily could have lost that series if Ottawa pulled out two more
games because then they would have won it four to two
[inaudible] you got a really hard time bringing it series home.
Um,
no,
they were really close games and uh,
Ottawa played like fucking,
you know,
they played great.
It wasn't great series and a fucking crushed me to watch Montreal when he should
be happy.
Montreal fence.
I'm a Bruins fans and uh,
it really hurt me that you guys want and I actually follow you guys.
I have the Montreal Canadian App on my phone and always goes five minutes to
gain tank.
Gets your snacks ready.
Ah,
it's so fucking awful kitschy snacks ready put on you.
Silly suck,
right?
Kits,
your snacks ready.
It gives me chills every time I read it.
But it makes me hate him more.
And I love it.
It's part of the game at this part of sports.
He got to have that team that you fucking hate.
You know,
sad.
I would be of Montreal Canadiens somehow that whole franchise folded,
I would be at a loss.
Who Do I hate the fucking saved.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I think they got their best chance.
I mean,
all the really big powerhouse,
powerhouse Western teams have kind of been dethroned the La Kings did make it
even though I thought they did,
they didn't even make the playoffs.
Vancouver's is shallow.
What?
They used to be there out of it.
St Louis looked like they were stacked to me,
you know,
and a bunch of fucking goal scores.
They're out of it.
I mean,
Minnesota is in,
it's so the ducks,
the ducks sex I think could surprise to people,
but um,
they just don't have like that.
Like,
you know,
like last year when the fucking Black Hawks and kings will come and you like,
all right,
whoever wins this fucking war is taking the cup.
You just know it.
You just knew it.
I'd not feel that.
And I've,
you know,
Black Hawks and under,
the longer you hang in there,
you get a little longer in the tooth.
I do feel that the Black Hawks are going to win it again.
MMM.
I Dunno,
I'm going to state the obvious.
It's either Black Hawks ranges are Canadians,
chief bill way to go out on a fucking limb.
And then I,
then I hedge my bet going,
but I'll tell you the ducks,
they could surprise.
Some people see that I basically picked air almost everybody that's still left.
So then I can be like,
dude,
what did I say?
What did I say on the last Monday of fucking April?
Do you guys want it in June?
I said this shit back in April.
I said it,
I should be coaching a team.
I'm the fucking dose that talks about shit like that.
Um,
20 years,
congratulations to Canadians.
You know,
you know,
my hatred for you really isn't to that level.
I do wish that you never win one,
but I also find it funny to hate like that.
Right.
Okay.
Anyways,
let me know what I have left here to talk about before I get into the goddamn
questions.
I do have to get back.
I have to get on a bus.
That's what I'm up fucking early and ride on my way over to Jackson.
You better not say that shit.
And Jack,
he better not to say that.
And Mississippi,
Jesus Christ,
they made me want to go home.
Um,
so anyways,
what am I going to do in Jackson,
Mississippi?
I have no idea.
Um,
but I,
I,
I am going to,
uh,
try to hang out with some locals,
maybe grab a beer with somebody and um,
then we're going to head down to mobile,
Alabama and I'm going to give myself a self guided tour of the USS Alabama,
or maybe at least at sub,
and then the tour's winding down.
All we have left is Kentucky and fucking,
uh,
Evansville.
And then we're on to the Kentucky Derby.
Um,
to,
you know what's hilarious is this whole trip,
we've all been like picking out what the fuck we're going to be wearing to the
derby.
Fucking Versie was looking at,
he wanted to keep by these white shoes with this white belt,
like fucking herb Tarlek and I'm telling,
I was like,
dude,
you gotta do it.
You got to dress like a complete jerk off and get a fucking hat.
That's,
that's what it is.
And a Oh Billy red face here.
I actually a I learned how to tie a bow tie,
you know,
accomplishment.
Um,
so we're fucking getting excited about that.
And um,
I guess the racist start at 10 30 in the morning and then they go all the way to
like the race,
which starts at like six 20 or something.
So experienced drinkers,
no.
All right.
I need to pace myself.
Okay.
So racist start at 10 30 in the morning.
Obviously you start with a screwdriver or a bloody Mary.
I just like a screwdriver because I feel like at least I'm fighting off a cold
while I'm fucking kicking my liver.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
I'll do it.
Speaking of which,
I didn't know what he wants right after that game,
we're going to leave and then we're going to go watch the fucking Mayweather
Pacquiao fight.
And um,
I dunno,
I think the safe bet is to be like,
oh,
fucking Mayweather's going to win a decision on points.
So then they have the rematch.
That's the safe thing.
What do I want to see?
I want to see somebody knock out the other guy.
It's kind of hard to root for that when,
you know they're getting a concussion and they getting fucking brain damage.
Um,
and it's also hard to root against Mayweather because of his record.
I'd like to see that guy get to 50,
you know,
but uh,
it's every time you watch like a fucking up when they hype a prize fight.
Yeah.
Once you see a guy that you think you don't like it,
then they just show his backstory and just like,
you can't be against them.
You know,
I saw this one on,
on,
on Mayweather
and uh,
you know,
he's showing me who he was 14,
he jumped on a boat and went to Malaysia.
Did speak the language of these other fighters.
It was like crying and stuff,
leaving his family.
He wanted to go back and then his best friend got killed in the ring and then he
had to go in right after him was fucking awful man slacking off.
So He's been through all of that shit right then may,
whether it comes from that dysfunctional family,
you know what I mean?
I don't fucking know.
I love her.
They're bringing up all this shit that the guy did in this past may,
whether we went to fucking jail for it and all that type of shit,
and it's just like ESPN,
this such fucking scumbags.
Like why?
Why are you bringing up his domestic violence now?
Because you give a shit about that or because you're out of shit to talk about.
It's so fucking dumb.
And then you're going to bring that up.
Like you're really doing some investigating,
reporting.
Like you really give a fuck about battered women and then he all you can.
Then you go right back to hype and the fight fight all the fucking century at
just fucking drives me up the Goddamn wall.
You know what I mean?
Then also these fucking groups,
you know,
that are trying to stop women from being battered.
They wait to this big fight to jump on the guy when he's promoting,
they come out of the woodwork.
It's like,
does it not matter that he battered women when he's not training for fight?
Oh fuck it.
This like watching somebody campaign for president.
Um,
it's like a strategic when you have to give a fuck and when you bring it up.
Well,
because if a lot,
if we give a fuck now,
which is pissing into the wind,
cause nobody's going to listen.
We got to wait to this guy's promoting something and then we strike.
Then we say we care.
Um,
anyways,
I don't fucking know.
I'm just hoping it's going to be a,
a,
that'd be a great fight.
I don't want to see me whether just fucking,
you know,
slipping every punch for another 12 rounds and as I stare at the fucking paper
view,
money going down the goddamn drain,
I love the fact that nobody can hit him,
but at some point it's like,
you want to see a fight?
Okay,
I just want to see somebody get hit.
Um,
all right.
This person wrote this fucking book called behind,
uh,
called uh,
okay.
It's coming out.
It's called a,
what the fuck is,
it's called Clinton cash and it's basically going to out the Clintons of how
they got their cash,
which is the funniest fucking thing ever.
To me.
It's like you could write Obama cash,
Bush cash,
anything but fucking Johnny Cash show.
Gvh You could do that about any fucking politician out here.
Where do they get the cash?
It's all salesy.
This is why I don't fucking get into this shit.
I can't do,
I just don't understand.
People who just sit around and they blame the problems of this country on
conservatives,
or they blame the problems of this country on the liberals,
the liberal agenda,
the corporate agenda.
It's like,
how about politicians don't make any fucking money at all yet.
They're all multimillionaires.
How about that?
How about this set up to be bribed?
Stop with this fucking horse shit of like,
you know,
uh,
there are public servants do.
They did this whole thing on senator senators make a couple hundred grand a
year,
which is nothing to sneeze and sneeze at.
But like the amount of them that are multi,
multi,
multi fucking millionaires,
they all get heads up on land deals.
They had their own private businesses that just go through the fucking roof.
It's the biggest fucking scam I've ever seen in my life.
And then if you bring it up,
everybody calls you conspiracy theorist and then they just sit there just
fucking blaming the other party.
This is adults that do that shit.
So I dunno what I,
I was,
I would recommend reading Clinton cash and just know that you could fucking
write that probably about every politician,
even Jimmy Carter who seemed to be like the best,
at least human being.
MMM.
Jimmy Carter.
What I loved about that guy was he handled the fucking hostage situation without
getting into a war with Iran.
We got everybody back.
You know
the one tragedy was when we tried to rescue them,
that midair collisions.
So some American servicemen did die,
all right?
But it was like single digits as opposed to what the fuck we got going on over
there now.
Which,
and you're not going to solve it.
Do you think you could have a war that would make Bruins and Montreal Canadien
fans like each other?
Yeah.
What?
We're going to hate each other,
hate each other back then.
We hate each other.
Now.
We're going to hate each other for fucking ever.
And that's how it works over there in the Middle East.
All right.
I Dunno,
I'm in way over my head here.
I'm just going to shut the fuck up.
Let's,
uh,
do a little more advertising here.
Then I'll read some.
Uh,
I'm gonna read some fucking average,
um,
some of your questions here for this week.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
All right?
You've heard me talking about dollar shave club.com.
The company that delivers amazing razors for a few bucks.
I know a razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shave seems too good to be true,
right?
Jesus Christ.
You have an itch behind your ear and that just makes you cough.
Fuck,
what is that?
Is it your you station tube?
I know a razor that costs a few bucks delivery.
A great shave seems too good to be true,
right?
But you really have to try the razors to dollar shave club.com razors.
We'll give you the most amazing shave that you've had in years.
Hey,
don't pay triple the price when you can get a fantastic shape delivered for just
a couple of dollars.
You'd have to be an idiot to keep overpaying.
You'd have to be,
why would you do that?
And then they get their fucking locked behind that little cage thing.
You got to wait for the old guy who should have retired,
but there was no money leftover because of those dicks on Wall Street.
So now he's got to be security at a cvs.
Yes,
I did just do air quotes.
Um,
anyways,
don't pay triple the price.
When you can get fantastic a shaved delivered for a couple of bucks,
you'd have to be an idiot.
I'm a massive celebrity everybody and I'm constantly getting my picture taken by
the Paparazzi or I'm on some TV show in high definition.
I cannot be seen with Nixon cuts all over my face.
I have to shave with a high quality fucking razor.
Don't be fooled by the price.
These razors are legit and you'll never go back.
Um,
plus they've got Dr Carver's easy shave.
It's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fasting,
Shay,
old fashioned shave foam,
you're a loser and I feel bad for you.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/bar today to get started.
You'll wish you had sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/bird dollar shave club.com/burr and uh,
lastly,
but not leastly an old favorite.
stamps.com everybody,
you know,
a lot of businesses get stuck doing things the old way,
just outta habit,
including vital operations like mailing and shipping.
That can be so damn time consuming.
If you still making trips to the post office,
you need stamps.com with stamps.com you can do all your mailing and shipping
right from your desk.
Never go to the post office again with stamps.com print postage for any letter
or package using your own computer and printer,
then handed,
then hand it to your mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox.
stamps.com is convenient and easy to use and you will save your money.
You'll get special postage discounts.
She can't even get at the post office.
I use stamps.com I use it to send out all my posters for this tour.
I am a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you special offer everybody right now?
Use My last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a hen $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up
to $55 in free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpeeyouarearethatstamps.com enter bar
mercifully the reading out loud portion is over for this week.
Um,
all right,
I got to get rolling here cause I'm going to jump on the bus in the next few
minutes.
Let's read here.
By the way,
everybody,
a couple of quick announcements here.
All right.
For the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday,
the Hashtag,
um,
if you want your questions read is,
uh,
is Hashtag t a m m p and send it to at the m m podcast.
Don't send it to at bill birth,
send it to at the MLM podcast.
Hashtag t a m m p uh,
you can tweet me articles,
videos,
questions,
anything you want me to go off on a just fuck around on Thursdays and a,
if you'd like to email the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
it's bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right,
let's get into the questions here for the week.
Um,
so god trailer,
hey bill promise.
I'm not trying to bust your ball a repeat.
This is not an attack.
Before the tour started,
you said you weren't going to mention the names of food places and cool spots to
visit.
Uh,
Rita called you out on not supporting local businesses and you justified your
position on the Thursday afternoon podcast just before Friday.
You talked about the cool cigar lounge built out of a trailer.
Just curious if this is an exemption or a harmless contradiction.
I repeat.
I'm not being a dick.
Thank you.
Know,
I actually thought about what that guy said.
If you've been listening to the podcast,
I actually,
uh,
mentioned the name.
Um,
but also it's the reason why I mentioned that guy was he went out of his fucking
way and he had like a 6,000 square foot fucking restaurant that he had to fill.
This wasn't some little mom and pop place in the corner that's been there
forever.
It was a brand new God damn business.
The guy totally hooked us up.
He kept it open after hours and all that stuff.
So I felt like I owed it to them,
but I gotta be honest with you,
as much as I gave that guy shit for giving me Shit,
you know,
I'm one of those guys,
he give me shit if,
if you're right,
I'll give you shit back.
And then it rolls around my big head for a couple of days and then I'll come
back and be like,
all right,
you're right.
You know?
I like to think that that makes me a fucking somewhat of an enlightened human
being.
If I was really enlightened in the moment,
I could stop.
Daddy would stop insulting.
It'd be like,
wait,
wait.
You know what?
You're right.
That's a big moment in your life.
Especially if you're an angry cunt like me to be able to stop mid argument and
just be like,
you know what?
You're right.
I'm sorry.
And then what's funny is it ends the argument and then you also get to see the
other person like frustrated because they want to keep yelling at you and now
they can't,
you know?
And then if they keep yelling,
then you get to be like,
dude,
I said,
you were right.
What the Fuck Modi you want from me?
And then they're actually the deck at that point.
You know,
it's a great thing to do.
All right.
Slumlord retirement bill,
I keep hearing you mentioned becoming a slum Lord and then retiring.
I'm actually doing something very similar,
but I'm not a slumlord dude.
I would never be a slum Lord.
I would never fuck people over.
Uh,
he,
he said I buy properties and low income area in,
in all cash,
fixed them up,
refinance them,
and then rent them out.
Every time I've done this,
I've gotten more cash out than I put in.
And the mortgage is always way less than the rent.
It's unbelievable.
But my thing is if you're in low income areas,
they're the first ones that get fired during a bad economy.
You know?
Then what do you do?
I couldn't,
I could not fucking evict somebody unless they were a complete piece of shit.
I don't know if I have the heart for this because I'd actually like to buy
something in a low income area of fix it up and give somebody a nice place,
a nice safe fucking place to live,
you know,
that wasn't a pressing.
Maybe give them hope and the kids try harder in school and they get the fuck out
of there.
That's what I'd like to do.
See,
I don't have the heart for this anyway.
So what was supposed to do is just be like,
yeah,
it looks fine.
Let people live in squalor,
have one toilet on each floor,
you know,
dark,
moist areas.
Bring back tuberculosis.
I'll make my money like the fucking asters to.
Um,
so what I'm trying,
so I'm sworn I'm struggling with now is if slash when I should quit my job,
I'll have enough rental income by the end of next year to replace my job.
I would love to just quit and hang out with my kids and just live a stress free
life.
But my wife has a different opinion.
She thinks I should keep my six figure job and just keep doing this in the on
the side because we would have way more money.
It's an easy office job,
so I see your point,
but I can't get over how amazing it would be to retire in my early thirties and
be able to spend my time however I want.
What do you think I should do?
What would you spend your free time doing?
Thanks.
Go Fuck yourself to first of all,
congratulations man on absolutely crushing it and making money work for you.
I know there's a lot of you guys listen to go.
Ooh.
Don't fucking six figures and could flow.
Can you?
Wouldn't most of you unfortunately would go out and spend six figures a year.
He'd go out and buy some flashy fucking car.
What does this guy do?
He went out and he,
he,
he made his money.
He reinvested it and made it work for him.
MMM.
What I think you should do is what your wife saying.
I would,
I would.
Okay.
Keep working for another 10 years and reevaluate and take that money.
That you making over the next 10 years and keep doing what you're doing and then
you'll really be able to retire.
Okay.
You'll be super comfortable.
MMM.
I gotta be honest with you.
Like what would I do if I were tired in my early thirties?
I would probably,
uh,
yeah,
I'd Kinda be bored shitless.
I would,
I like working.
I like tore.
And I like doing all of that.
Like when I say that I will,
I'll,
I'll exit out of this business.
What I really mean is I'll be in a position in this business where I won't have
to do anything I don't want to do.
I won't have to embarrass myself.
I won't have to go on dancing with the stars and all of that Shit.
You know,
whatever the fuck you do whenever you,
your career is tanking.
MMM.
But I think what you're doing is fucking amazing.
And that's what people need to do is you got to learn how to make you money.
Can either fucking set you free or it can fucking enslave you.
And I didn't know shit about money and I just keep reading it.
And reading and reading and I baby stepped my way into learning about it.
And that's how I ended up having this fucking opinion on bankers and what they
do to people.
And it's an absolute sin that they don't teach you about money.
Three the most important fucking thing when you're in school.
So,
but fortunately there's libraries and books are free there.
MMM.
That you can,
you can educate yourself the greatest education other than staying away from
drugs wearing a condom and shit like that.
MMM.
You got to do what you're doing,
man.
I think that's fucking great that you're doing it.
Um,
I would,
uh,
I dunno if I would lose it if I went to a low income area,
I would,
I would fix the fucking thing up,
but I would do it in a way that they wouldn't make the other people in the area.
MMM.
Two too jealous that would make them want to go in there and rob the people.
But the,
the guts of the fucking building,
I would make sure that I did it up right.
And people would not have fucking leaky sinks in that type of shit.
I'd make sure that they were fine.
Uh,
my only concern,
like I said,
was that they're the first ones who get fucking hatchet.
And when the economy tanks cause diagnosed the concept the top,
they're not going to cut off their own fucking arm.
You know,
those poor people would need that.
He can't expect people to do that.
So anyways,
congratulations.
I hope to be in your position someday,
sir.
It's a,
it's a goal of mine.
All right.
Pacquiao versus Mayweather,
a bill.
Is this a legit fight in your opinion?
Do we have a dog in this fight?
It's absolutely legit fight.
And um,
I like both of these guys and uh,
I'm just hoping it's going to be a great fight.
I'm sorry to give you that country fucking response.
But if I had to pick somebody,
I just love how may were the talks,
all that shit.
He's got those cars and he throws his money and it pisses everybody off a fuck.
I really liked both of these guys and I love that packy out came from absolutely
fucking nothing.
Um,
and that he sings and he fucking,
he becomes a senator and all this other shit.
Um,
I love both of these guys.
Okay.
It's going to be weird to see one of them loose.
Um,
but it better not be a fucking draw.
I can tell you that.
All I know is I'm going to be fucking wearing a pink bow tie with a matching
fucking thing in my pocket and as see us soccer that go,
you watching it like that.
That's all I know.
Uh,
did we dressed in linen?
All right,
when I go to watch it.
All right.
Dental health,
dear Billy.
Wisdom teeth.
Um,
my wife thinks I have perfect teeth and says I don't do enough to deserve them.
I floss occasionally,
usually brush twice a day and I've never had any cavities.
I'm 42.
She says it's genetics.
She is to do a ton more to achieve the same whiteness.
Just wondering what your thoughts are on the genetics.
Arguments make sense to me.
Look at the Brits.
Um,
you know something,
I don't know what the deal is with their fucking teeth.
I mean,
they're not as bad as everybody makes him out to be,
but,
um,
there's definitely an issue over there,
a stereotype,
but it's spot on.
Okay.
What at that,
that's a sentence,
a stereotype,
but a spot on what at that all right.
What are your rituals having worked in the dental office,
some of those mouthwashes that boasts whitening actually stained teeth according
to a class action lawsuit.
Yeah.
I just brushed my teeth in the morning and the evening and then I floss.
I don't have any cavities either.
MMM.
Yeah,
I would see.
there's definitely genetic cause this type of people that have that brush and
floss and all that,
and then just their,
their teeth,
they rot out of their fucking heads.
I don't know what they're doing.
Um,
I do know that when you eat sugary stuff,
uh,
it's not the sugar that eats away your teeth.
It feeds bad bacteria in your mouth that attack your teeth.
I think I do remember that from my days working in a dental office,
but my ritual is every six months I get my teeth cleaned.
Um,
and my ritual is also,
if the guy says,
I have a cavity,
I get a second opinion.
That's only happened one time and I didn't.
Sometimes they misread x rays and they'll dig into a perfectly good fucking
tooth and then you got a filling and then if shit gets under the filling next
scene or you need a root canal,
then it gets pulled in and need a partial,
then you need dentures.
It just goes down the fucking hill.
So,
um,
if you don't have any cavities and somebody says you have a cavity,
always get a second opinion.
Um,
that's all I can tell you.
And other than that,
brush twice a day,
not three times floss.
MMM.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I,
you scope or Listerine.
I haven't had a problem with them standing your fucking teeth.
Uh,
so why don't you use mouthwash first and then brush your teeth?
It's pretty easy.
I would stay away from red wine.
As you're drinking it,
you smile at somebody,
you have great teeth.
He like a fucking vampire.
All right.
Fiances,
gay best friend,
a Billy red state tourist.
Uh,
I need some advice from you and maybe Nia,
I apologize if I spelled it right now.
You didn't.
Uh,
she has the time.
Well,
unfortunately I'm on the road here.
Uh,
my fiance is living with me and also carrying my baby girl who was doing August.
Congratulations.
She's been friends with this gay guy for a long time.
She says he's the only one who can make her laugh so hard.
She almost pisses herself.
I'm fine that they are close and I'm fine with them being gay.
I was raised in Texas where homosexuality is,
isn't as welcome.
There is some places,
especially since I went to a Baptist church all of my life before your rant,
it was never a hate gays kind of preaching.
It was more of a homosexual.
He is unbiblical and it's a sin.
Love them anyway.
You guys save yourselves in the end.
Um,
anyway,
my perspective is people are free to do what they want as long as they don't
impose it on me.
She went to spend a few days with her gay friend and his boyfriend,
and when she came back she told me a few stories about the fun they had,
including when he had to use the restroom so bad.
He went in while she was showering.
I'm not against them being friends,
but I think he should have had enough respect for me as a man to not walk into
the bathroom.
Why,
why a woman was in the shower,
gay or not.
He still has a dick and shouldn't walk into a shower.
Another man's woman is naked.
Should I bring this up or should I leave it be,
if I should,
if I should bring it up.
What should I say without hurting her feelings?
Keep in mind she is pregnant and hormonal,
uh,
love.
You.
Love the show.
The Texan.
Um,
I would have,
I would just have a ps.
My baby has a high chance of being a redhead.
Lots of reds on her side in mind,
including both of our mothers were.
There you go.
You'll have a funny little bastard.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
You have a,
you have a daughter.
She'll be a hot shit then.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
what would I say?
I would,
I would have an adult conversation with them.
Just say,
listen man,
I'm not trying to be a dick.
Um,
it's not cool.
That's not cool for you to be going in there.
Um,
when my wife is in there.
All right.
I,
I just,
and then what's the and what's,
I don't know,
I don't know how you say this to the guy.
Just as a man,
you know,
I don't want you going in and going to the bathroom while my wife is naked in
the shower.
Okay.
That's it.
And by like,
you know,
I'm gay or whatever,
as I listen,
I don't care.
I don't care that you're gay.
You know,
I,
I don't have any problem with you being gay.
I have a problem with you going in naked while my wife is in the shower.
Okay.
You crossing a line there and I don't want you to cross that line again.
That's it.
We're call and I would leave it at that and I wouldn't even tell you wife about
it.
And if he tells you wife and she brings it up with you,
just say,
listen,
I'm not comfortable with that.
I don't want another naked man peeing while you're in the shower.
I don't think that's unreasonable.
Okay.
And if she gives you shit to just be like,
look,
can you just respect me on this?
Okay.
We had it out.
He agreed with me.
All right,
I'm doing this because I love you.
go put it on the real housewives.
I'll sit here with you.
But just,
you know,
there's,
if there's a line here,
I think you're totally within your rights,
just in general.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
no,
I don't want you to do that.
Okay.
You're fucking right to say that just because you say no to somebody who's gay
does not,
you know,
it does not make you fucking homophobic.
They are human beings and they're capable of,
of crossing lines.
He crossed the line.
You don't like it.
It's not.
It has nothing to do with him being gay has to with the fact that he's a man.
He treated them like a fucking man.
You treat him the way he treated straight,
man.
There's nothing wrong with that.
At least I don't think so.
No.
Jesus.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody,
uh,
if you'd like to donate to the podcast now,
there's a very way easy way to do it that,
um,
does not include you spending any money.
Next time you go to amazon.com just swing by a bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page.
You Click on the Amazon link on the right hand corner or right hand mid page.
It takes you right to Amazon and I get credit for driving traffic there.
They kicked me a little bit of cash.
Um,
and it doesn't cost you any extra money if you'd like to do it.
Thank you.
If you don't,
I respect it.
Whatever.
That's the deal.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
I'll check in with you guys on Thursday.
Have a nice couple of days in a read up on money.
We end up on money.
Get your money to fucking work for you.
Um,
I highly recommend you do not put it in the fucking stock market.
I think that's the biggest fucking scam ever.
I am a big believer in buying,
investing in something that you could walk up to and touch as opposed to,
I have shares.
Where are they?
I Dunno,
man.
They were in the air,
I don't know where they are.
Right.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you in a few days.